il y a plus de risque à rester chez soi
que d'aller à l'école jean michel
blanquer re persiste et signe
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
garde son cap inchangé depuis le début
de la pandémie
accusé de ne pas avoir retardé la
rentrée scolaire en raison de la
situation sanitaire toujours très
préoccupante
il s'est défendu d'avoir mis en danger
les enfants après l'apparition en france
du variant britannique ducobu 19 ne pas
aller à l'école nuit' énormément aux
enfants sur le plan éducatif social et
même sur le plan sanitaire
cela peut être très négatif sur les
plans psychologique et physique nous
devons sans arrêt durant toute cette
crise avoir comme première priorité les
enfants les adolescents et les jeunes
parce que ce qu'ils vivent plus obérer
leur futur si nous n'y prenons garde
mais pour penser au futur encore faut-il
assurer le présent
le virus continue de se propager dans
l'hexagone le nombre de cas positifs
tourne autour de 20 milles depuis
plusieurs jours l'objectif c'est de
maintenir le plus possible les enfants à
l'école
notre boussole c'est de dire que la
dernière chose qu'il y aurait à fermer
en cas de durcissement des mesures c'est
l'école le milieu scolaire n'est pas
plus contaminés que le reste de la
société
sauf que voilà en situation d'école
ouverte les 12 16 ans ont cette fois
plus de risques que les plus de 17 ans
d'introduire le comique 19 au sein d'un
foyer à c'est la conclusion d'un récent
rapport des sages
un groupe d'experts scientifiques et
c'est loin d'être la seule étude en ce
sens
la dernière en date est suisse elle
affirme que la fermeture des écoles au
sens du pays a drastiquement réduit la
transmission du virus
la fermeture des écoles a réduit la
mobilité de 21,6 pour cent notre analyse
confirme que la fermeture des écoles est
une mesure qui permet de réduire la
vitesse de circulation du virus par la
réduction des déplacements
l'équipe de chercheurs suisses a analysé
1 milliard 500 millions de mouvements
entre le 10 février et le 26 avril 2020
pour ce faire elle a utilisé des données
des opérateurs mobiles helvétique pour
évaluer l'impact des mesures contre le
comique 19 sur la mobilité
si les écoles sont fermées on peut
espérer un grand changement dans les
comportements non seulement les enfants
restent à la maison mais ça implique
aussi parfois un changement pour les
parents un changement pour les parents
c'est peut-être là que le bât blesse
pour l'état français
l économie étant déjà en crise en raison
de la pandémie
la fermeture des écoles pourraient
empêcher de nombreux parents de
poursuivre leur activité professionnelle
situation qui dégraderaient davantage la
situation économique s ce qui a guidé
les choix stratégiques du gouvernement
quoi qu'il en soit l'allemagne le
royaume-uni l'autriche et une vingtaine
d'autres pays dans le monde ont préféré
jouer la carte de la sécurité est
enfermé leur école